a lot of my early investments Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr had started becoming
big and I was really trying to decide
what I wanted to do with my career in
2011 I took over in September 2011 I
took over kind of being the CEO of the
agency we were 29 people and in the last
four years I grew up from 30 people to
now we're almost 600 people so I think
what happened in that period of time was
a couple of other things which was you
have a feeling a lot of people here
don't know who I am I grew up in a
liquor store in New Jersey and grew my
dad's liquor business from a three to a
seventy million dollar business in five
years using EECOM email marketing Google
AdWords and banner ads so I'd been the
byproduct of not having a lot of money
in a small family business
deploying it against the arbitrage of
where the market thought media should go
versus where I thought it should go and
felt the actual selling of stuff results
of it so when I got into the agency
world I think what has been our
disproportionate advantage is I truly
want to sell the product I really I
really I'm not too worried about our own
margin because I'm land-grabbing
I'm not too worried about awards because
I think that's a proxy to get more
talent and more clients and I feel like
I'm good at that I just really really
wanted to sell stuff because I thought
that that would give us the best air
cover to actually keep business and grow
business a funny thing happens we've all
we're all in the game right you sit in
these rooms and everybody's high-fiving
themselves for great modeling media mix
results and Nielsen's health results and
everybody's high-fiving I came from a
pure business background where like the
sales were to sale I would literally sit
in these meetings and everybody's like
everything's great like the PR company
would walk in and say we got eight
hundred eighty seven trillion
impressions for this but you know
placement and then you know somebody
else would come in and say this was the
greatest lift the ROAS and everything
was so great and then you know I'm just
kind of really was naive eyes I would
say real quick I kind of read the brief
coming into this isn't our business down
29% and then everybody be like yeah but
there must be something and like yes
you're quantifying the wrong [ __ ]
so how do you quantify the right [ __ ] I
like that you're coming along for this
ride
I think you quantify it and I think this
is you know it's funny I think you do it
a lot of my clients who either were fans
of my work or we're excited to work with
us a lot of our junior clients or
sometimes the senior client because I
came from high levels cuz I had a lot of
relationships they would always be
perplexed by our meetings in 2011 12 and
13 specifically I think and even now
they're always like man you like with
meeting would end they'd be my rabbi in
this situation and they would say man
you really don't have to make your work
so want to file so I think the way you
measure the right stuff is you actually
force your client you suffocate the
conversation into putting everything on
the line and justifying the spent now
that's hard I come from econ it was easy
right and I owned the liquor store it
was easy I'd run direct mail I'd see the
customer count go up I'd run banner you
know I just quantified everything cuz I
had the full funnel when you know we
have Pepsi we have Unilever
you know we have when we have these kind
of clients it's kind of hard they're
selling in a big-box stores there's a
lot of other media running at the same
time you don't have the feedback loop
you can't you know connect the dots I
find it fascinating that right now if
you ask me who our happiest clients were
at vaynermedia they're all the clients
in EECOM because they couldn't quantify
our success black and white there is
just no debate I think what you try to
do is create tests or controlled
environments a lot of my CPG clients I
asked them can you give me we have major
alcohol brands I know because I come
from the alcohol industry that the state
of Pennsylvania is a liquor controlled
state the state sells everything I
always say to them hey let me run my
stuff just in Pennsylvania
you've got your baseline sales then we
can actually see if that's will work so
I'm always the one in the room you know
it's funny I bet most people in this
room and I have empathy for why you
think this thinks that social media is
still struggling to find its ROI and
things of that nature I actually think
it's you know for me in the world that I
live in it's the most black-and-white
place if you
Wow a black and white place environment
to justify it I think a lot of times
people think that I'm rode with my ideas
and I feel like I'm the most practical
person ever the only North Star I have
is create absolutely no debate if the
things that you're doing are driving the
business what you have to do is you have
to get the client to tell you the truth
of what the business is and then you've
got to try to reverse-engineer and sell
it and the only thing I try to follow is
people's attention and if you're in this
room right now and you don't realize
that people's attention is in a phone
and disproportionately within social
networks of that phone well then you're
just not paying attention and
interesting if you look at massive
social networks and that's why the
investment there has grown because there
is no debate we're in the u.s. Wernham
in a world where everybody is justifying
everything on reports and everybody here
knows that everybody in this room is
capable of reverse engineering a report
to justify the spent so we're playing an
inside [ __ ] game the end and by the
way let's make this point 50% of the
swing just looked me dead in the face
and shook their heads yes that in itself
needs to be debated and what the [ __ ] is
going on right we know I mean people
know but they're playing within the
confines of the game and I have empathy
for that you've got bosses you've got
numbers the head you got your own you
got rent college loans
I get it but that doesn't that's a
separate conversation to what actually
drives business do you find that your
clients are set up to give you the data
so you could even prove those numbers
though is there a problem with a lot of
client systems or not not set up
themselves so how do the agencies could
be doing so much more in real time if
they were getting quicker daters that
are dated like three months down the
line which has been 100 percent yes but
I'll go to I'll go further I think a lot
of our clients and I'm not mad at them
either I've been but before their game
they play the same damn game actually
don't want everything to be black and
white because it's not interested it's
not in their vested interest that they
live in a corporate environment where
they've invested into going through a
certain path they know the check boxes
they have to hit for their own interest
and they run through that path and I
respect that that machine creates that
environment I used to be mad at them but
I'm like oh no no no this is the
company's fault for creating that
environment
so you know it's listen it's complicated
but for me what kind of gives me the
energy I'm projecting right now is there
needs to be two separate conversations
not one blended one which really breaks
down into let's recognize why we do
certain things but then let's also have
a totally separate conversation to the
ROI of what these things are doing I
mean it is so much easier for me to
justify the ROI of digital behavior than
traditional behavior and it's not even
close and so I sit around in rooms where
lore'l as a client of ours and they're
completely mixed up and why this isn't
working and then a company that I wrote
the first investment check into called
Birchbox was gone from zero to four
hundred million in revenue and does all
their behavior through a Pinterest
Facebook and Instagram environment and
can quantify every damn cent including
what you're seeing now happening in
marketing which is uber and airbnb and
all these startups now have a lot of
money and they're starting to do some
traditional media because they've
saturated digital and they're curious
and they're all my homies from that
world because that's where I came from
or calling me and they're like hey Gary
can you tell me how we need to quantify
television I go I have no [ __ ] idea
at some GRP or [ __ ] I don't know and so
they you know like there's you know it's
a very for me it's super funny because I
literally live two separate lives I live
fëanor medias life where have big
clients who've accepted traditional
metrics as the KPIs
while they don't match their actual
business results and then I have my
startup cultural world with all my
startups where everything has to be
quantifiable and none of the traditional
stuff they can wrap their head around it
is literally bizarro world
so you thinking in a funny way
appetising has had a measurement system
over the years that everyone's bought
into so it's kind of worked because they
we bought into it but it's actually not
that based on reality of course like of
course that's how Awards have any value
in this industry because it's a proxy
that you can leverage against it's it's
insanity when you come to it in fresh
eyes it's insanity so do these terms
like advertising media anymore I mean of
course they do I mean listen on the flip
side I understand the energy I bring to
the table like I believe in all this
stuff I believe in marketing and sales
and branding and I believe in it with
all my heart I just feel that the way
we're quantifying the results is
backwards I mean of course a great video
that somebody sees and changes their
emotion makes them want to buy things
like it of course but how many people in
this room actually watch a commercial is
really fascinating I mean here's the
funny Twitter data point everybody
spends money on sports advertising
because people watch sports my friends
once and for all there's a very big
difference between watching television
and consuming television commercials
nobody's saying everybody's stopping and
wait watching break people gonna watch
Breaking Bad the second a commercial
this this smart of an audience the
second a commercial goes on in your
household you directly grab your phone
and you pick up on your work or you talk
about LeBrons awesome dunk you were
definitely not watching some Jeep
drive up a [ __ ] mountain and that's
just as that's just as true of live
sports otherwise you what you don't
catch up the sec guys let me tell you
about my biggest mistake professionally
so far I wrote a book in 2009 it was
called crush it it kind of put me on the
map and talked about social media if you
go to the acknowledgments of that book I
I think my entire family and one random
human being
Travis Cal Connect Travis is the CEO of
uber and one of my best friends I passed
on investing in uber you heard about the
good ones let me tell you about the bad
ones
uber I pass
investing in uber twice twice he begged
me the second time at four million
dollar valuation it's at a sixty billion
dollar valuation the normal fifty
thousand dollar check that I write that
if I would have written to that
investment would be worth 196 million
dollars okay now let's talk about this
it sucks but when when uber came to New
York Travis hit me up I was out of town
so he went to go see my brother AJ my
brother AJ took the first-mover ride in
New York City he is rider zero he tested
it when he tested it it hit me he
watered it in vaynermedia's old office
we were 20 people and he went downstairs
and there it was and it hit me holy crap
uber doesn't sell transportation uber
sells time my friends uber sells time
time in the 24 hour 365 day world that
we now all live in has become
dramatically more valuable because I'm
not a kid I grew up in a time where the
world did stop the work time at six
seven eight I was a workaholic I worked
till nine right like I grew up in that
environment now it's 24/7 as you guys
know clients there's you get an email at
11:00 p.m. plenty of people expect you
to reply at 11:01 especially if they
know you go to sleep at midnight right
like we were on right we are on so time
has become dramatically more valuable do
you know what advertising does in our
society right now the way it's
structured it feels your time it takes
the one thing you care about now more
than Europe besides health and money
time is the only thing you guys care
about and it is now stealing your time
you went to espn.com to read an article
you didn't come there for a pop-up ad
for Samsung to force you to watch a
video for 30 seconds you went to watch a
kid fall off a tree on YouTube you
income for that 50 cent 15-second
pre-roll for Nissan right this is not
what we came for
advertising is it's structured now
steals your time it worked in 1972 when
you sat on your goddamn ass and you
didn't have a remote control and happy
days was rolling through and you saw the
popcorn ad that's fine but as soon as
the remote control came
started the process of technology
shifting away from consumption and
that's the game technology is now moving
so quickly that it's starting to give us
back what we want when tipo was invented
that was a problem for the commercial
it's now playing itself out that's just
the way it's gonna be
and so that's it and now I mean I've
been talking about this for three years
I'm like wait to the operating systems
block your ads well here we are finally
iOS is update it's bad if you're buying
on the banner exchange it's bad and it's
great for the end consumer so we're
gonna have to reinvent what advertising
means and what I think advertising needs
to mean to really be effective is it
needs to bring you value and value comes
in the form of entertainment value comes
in the form of utility it comes in a lot
of different forms but the mechanisms
the days of I want to read this magazine
I'm gonna turn the page to finish my
article oh wait a minute here's a makeup
ad I got to go around it that stole my
second that second used to mean jack
[ __ ] that second matters now let me show
you how by show of hands how many people
in this room we've got to go on us now
how many people in this room are now
upset when another human being
calls them raise your hand hold it high
hold it high real quick I just want to
see this raise it higher I want
everybody to see this look around
everybody
hold it keep it hold it my man 60% of
this room is actually upset
what any time a human being
calls them think about that that is
unbelievable when I ask this question
two and a half years ago most people
didn't understand what I was referring
to like a couple of people raise their
hands everybody else would look at them
you know calling somebody that was just
a normal way we communicated what we've
all figured out in this room is why are
you conduct why are you trying to
communicate with me on your time this is
my time you stole something of value for
me while you tried to sell me your [ __ ]
so the people in this room would
probably say that actually the future of
advertising is PR because if PR
relationship is important relationship
where the person has made a conscious
decision to access that kind of or to
engage with that brand etcetera what do
you think of that I think PR has its own
set of challenges because I think in
general where we consume our media from
is changing right and you know I think
of I think in the world of social media
and by the way real quick I on social
media just for kicks and giggles I truly
believe that social media is a slang
term for the current state of the
Internet
I mean there's nothing social media
about Pinterest these are media content
platforms Twitter is probably the
closest thing to an actual social media
platform right but Twitter and Facebook
if you google it right now we're both
referred to web 2.0 sites we always need
a word to kind of sum things up it's
just the current state of the internet
and the current state of the Internet is
there's massive fragmentation and media
you know media publications as we
traditionally knew them are getting are
being competed with with human beings
with micro media country you know sites
and so this long tail of PR is the
challenge how do you really get the
value plus there's so many human
individuals now that can create
awareness so I think PR challenges like
everybody's challenge which is it's
getting spread wide I'm not I mean look
I think PR I think everything's great hi
by the way I think the Superbowl
commercial ad is massive
underpriced I think the Super Bowl
commercial ad is probably worth 25
million dollars because every human
being in America is going to see it
whether they see it that day or the week
before on YouTube now the creative is
the variable if you're going to be
successful but there's there I have no
heart to like-new I mean as a matter of
fact when my clients call me and said
Gary great news we're going 50% digital
I usually get even more scared because I
know what that means is banner pre-roll
video pre-roll on YouTube
buying [ __ ] on the exchange where
they don't even know where that creative
shows up it's the bottom left-hand
corner of some cockamamy and website
that's running a facebook arbitrage
media backend like like it's to me it's
just show me where the attention is and
so if PR is placed in a place that
everybody's reading and it brings
positive brand equity to that brand
that's great I just think it's a you
know I think people the people might be
our friends I was I made the joke
already I think we have to have solid
metrics there you can't take credit for
the monthly traffic of a website and
quantify your article 16 links deep on
that website as how many impressions
that article got and there's a lot of
that practice just like in social media
there's a lot of practice of somebody
getting a tweet from a celebrity and
quantifying that 14 million people saw
it how about zero people saw it how
about the fact that Twitter's got such a
firehose problem that nobody's consuming
anything on that platform as much as
they used to because they didn't create
an algorithm and that created their
vulnerability because time matters so
much to us that we'd rather just scream
through it then actually unfollow
somebody how about that yes sir good on
NASA the audience so I think how many
questions last one for me when you
started doing you Facebook consultancy
it's a very different environment yes
the channels change every week you can
construct a strategy and Facebook will
change and he'll posters freedom
primarily paid now what are you advising
your car you mean like every other media
platform in the world well well yes you
do know here's I mean this is TV no but
your buddy no no I mean you know I don't
mean it changes which I agree with I
mean everybody got so emotional that you
have to pay for Facebook right they they
flip the rug from underneath us it used
to be organic everything is paying to
play and more importantly it's effective
so while people still reconciled with
their feelings the best executors and
practitioners disproportionate took
value of the under priced marketplace
that it created as far as changing the
goal posts and things of that nature so
did TV at first used to do sponsorship
at Sullivan's show is brought to you by
Lincoln Towncar
then somebody came up with the model of
the 30-second ad and the market moved
we're at the beginning they're changing
tough luck like the markets hard nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you
like the end like nobody that like you
don't pissed I am the social media came
along I had digital figured out I build
the biggest business on it I loved SEO
like I was all about banner retargeting
I followed your asses until you gave up
and want wine for free I mean I did it I
had it it was good like you know fun it
was for me with YouTube YouTube was four
months old when I started Wine Library
TV tons of people were watching me like
I loved it like like this is exhausting
I'm pissed like [ __ ] now we have like
really we have animated [ __ ] selfie
things like rainbows are coming out of
my mouth I get it like like you've got
to keep up with this [ __ ] 24/7 I'm
getting old I turned 40 in November I'm
pissed but nobody cares like sorry
[ __ ] Toland Springs nobody cares that
the world is moving that's what's gonna
happen and it's our job to figure out
how to bring value to those people to do
what we want them to do and that's just
the market that's look some dude bought
eight thousand horses before the car was
invented
he lost right
like like the market moved on him the
the price of a horse declined and and so
and so to sit around and be upset that
innovations moving and you wish it was
the way it was is fine you're more than
welcome it's just a it's a proxy to
losing always yes please
my whole crews sitting right behind you
can start it now this is why he needs
watch the askgaryvee show thank you yes
opening it please what is your view of
Facebook now I think Facebook right this
minute is one of the single best ad
products in the last 20 years of
marketing the people using Facebook seem
to be getting older great they have more
money you're welcome and I'll give you
more so we're not just entertaining
don't forget Facebook owns Instagram and
now we're deploying that logic there I
mean this is why zux is so smart he's
always tried to buy attention so I
offered three billion for snapchat
imagine we were sending a room right now
and Facebook own Facebook Twitter and
snapchat they do own the entire
ecosystem thirteen two seventy right
and so Facebook's incredible I mean
we're we're like seventy year olds six
year olds fifth year olds and fifty
sixty and seventy are paying attention
so carefully to their feed they're
converting at a scary rate right thirty
and forty are still very much they are
converting at ridiculous scale what's
even scarier if you're an actual
practitioner you realize that twenty one
to twenty five is converting like crazy
they might not be there sixteen times a
day like they used to but you only need
them to check once you didn't watch
friends eighty seven times right you
watch it once we got the commercial in
front of you good so
I mean III think it's it's stunningly
good
I think Instagram in 2016 will probably
be the best all-time ad product ever
because while people debate the ROI and
is anybody over 40 on it and all these
dumb things we always do or while media
buying agencies try to quantify if they
can make enough money against their
sponsor you know against their Vig with
their client and so if they can't they
won't recommend it while that's all
happening there's gonna be ungodly
amounts of attention on Instagram ads
that are going to convert because it's
early the supply demand curve is
disproportionately valuable yeah let's
talk about that I think it's a great
question or in the old days we took our
opinion from three old white men that
owned all the media companies and told
you what to think
well there's two options you think of it
from the undereducated masses or you
take it from the educated puppets of the
billionaires that drove the agenda that
they wanted down your mouth hey hey all
right so you mentioned how pop-up ads
and all about steel are times yes what
our views on native ads like the
listicles and BuzzFeed we're you know
like a kitty litter company yeah I think
that um it's a great question I think
that it has the same slide as everything
look I think Facebook I think social
media ads are gonna disproportionately
get worse they're gonna get more
expensive because more people gonna
realize they work we're gonna tune them
out more as we become adjusted to that
behavior right so I think a lot of the
BuzzFeed type stuff at first did really
well because it was really native in the
beginning the brand was really
integrated two or three years ago like
in the list at a picture of it
and it was new ish and they did better
now we're so used to everything saying
18 weird things that happen on Thursday
that we're tuning out the 18 and 12 and
the 9s as much as we you know love them
three years ago as a collective data set
plus the brands are not integrated as
well because bus beats scaled and now 13
funny things that happen at home is like
brought to you by tide in a little box
and it's not really integrated
so they've scaled which is
disproportionately brought less value in
my opinion to the brand I think it's
still a great option I think there's
value there I think you got to push it
creatively to get there but it's all the
same game I have no heart for anything
I know 360 videos coming I know virtual
reality's coming I know we have contact
lenses that allow us to record
everything like there's a plenty of
technology and innovation coming I just
think it's important that we always
audit where the actual attention really
is and then reverse-engineer if the
price is disproportionately valuable at
that moment and then you just look for
those moments so I think you know two
years ago it was massively bullish today
I still think that it's better than a
crap load I mean do you know much money
is being bought programmatic where
nobody knows where that shows up and
nobody's consuming it so like those
digital dollars I feel fine in a
BuzzFeed world but compared to a
Facebook targeted where I can target a
29 year old woman who has two kids who I
know buys toothpaste get the hell out of
here right I mean Facebook is like FSI
4.0 if you want to go conversion it's
it's it and it doesn't kill your brand
cuz you actually can mark it it's better
than search because those are just blue
letters it does nothing for your brand
but here you can go visual pictures or
video and listen the reef if they keep
the dislike button is such a smart proxy
to where they're going which is they
just want their data to be smarter and
smarter and smarter they tweak
everything predicated if they see a dip
and user behavior not using it they
analyze it to the cows come home and
adjust the product because they've been
smart enough to realize the only thing
they have is their users their entire
business is that so they will
disproportionate rie to bring you value
and they will stop ads if it doesn't
bring you don't buy a placement in
Viacom and then the ad shows up the
commercial and they say you know what
that's a shitty ad we're not gonna
charge you for running that we're gonna
stop it they just take the money because
they don't care about the audience
there's no
oxi there whereas facebook stuck into
that they know that you've always been a
disrupter and it's amazing how fast
you've grown vaynermedia yeah from sort
of your own I remember when early days
you were on a like a stepstool in New
York just sort of spouting out thinking
he's not much of chicken [ __ ] what do
you think though is you're earning all
this business and your agency is growing
so rapidly what is it that you're
bringing from big perspective of
disruption that's eating you all this
clients interaction we're proving that
we're selling stuff it's so crazy like
every single time I hear you've always
been known as a disruptor literally when
you said that in my mind it said out of
practicality I just think I truly
believe in the entire ecosystem of
agency world I truly believe that on the
single most practical no I mean there's
nothing as dead or alive but you know
it's not that it's dead anybody who
doesn't bring value should die right and
so I think what's gonna happen is if
somebody if somebody's romantic about
what should be done if somebody is
romantic about a television 30-second
spot there you're gonna create
themselves of vulnerability as data
continues to prove out its lack of our
ally right and so but can a 30-second
commercial be tremendous of course again
I think what's gonna happen is the
market is going to continue to push
itself look you can't have an
environment where method does all its
proper digital work and starts really
getting on the radar of Unilever and J&J
and saying wait they laughed Proctor and
Gamble laughed at Dollar Shave Club
until they didn't and so eventually this
stuff plays itself out right like
everybody made fun of me in 1996 for
launching an e-commerce wine business in
the wine world this kid is going to do
this yeah people are going to buy wine
on the world
right like like nobody's gonna do that
and some of you remember this and some
of you won't raise your hand for this
some of you thought it was a fad like
the Internet this thing is 20 years old
this is new and so and then everybody
justified that it was a fad cuz Wall
Street played its game and overvalued
everything so when it crumbled and was
like see told you meanwhile Amazon was
becoming the single most important
retailer so I think that I think that
the reason it's working for us is I'm
not scared to get fired at all I run I
usually so look at all the advantages I
have in building my business model you
guys know this world better than I do my
first year on 99% of my clients is a
loss I massively over-deliver on the
scope because I'm trying to build
lifetime value so right off the bat
I'm winning I don't have some person
telling me to dictate at a holding
company that I have to run in 21 points
right I have to look at myself and know
what I'm up to
so I disproportionate over bring value
we really know what we're talking about
on this subject matter you know why cuz
the CEO is the best practitioner addict
in the whole [ __ ] company that helps
when it stems from the top nobody can
sneak around and shoot hyperbole that
isn't true that's important and then
because I need them to last for two to
three years to make a business model
work for me in a world where I lose if
they fire me after one year I
disproportionally pressure them into
quantifying my work because once I prove
that when they start do you know what
starts happening when real smart people
actually get it and understand that
we're selling stuff do you understand
what happens to the questions they start
asking all their other partners do you
no silly the conversation becomes how
fast that becomes silly when they know
my stuff selling and they have no idea
what the hell your stuffs doing thank
you
thank you